the eyes to the right 202 the nose to  the left  432 the eyes to the right 200 there we  haven't see withdrawal and wings  defeated by a majority of two hundred  and thirty two hundred and two voting  for the Prime Minister's with all  agreement 432 MPs saying no to tourism a  faisal islam our political editor and  that's right at the top land of  expectations as a point of all their  horrific results the house does not  support this deal but tonight's vote  tells us nothing about what it does  support nothing about how  [Applause]  nothing about how or even if it intends  to honor the decision the British people  took in a referendum Parliament decided  to hold